[Applause]
right on huh nice ah yeah keep going
happy Wednesday everybody oh I'm so
excited as you know it's National
Women's History Month ah and what am I
doing to celebrate it I'm buying every
women in my life a new ironing board
a sexist would say
I think at this point we could lose that
we saw Hershey's putting a transgender
woman on their chocolate bars to
celebrate this magical month yeah sorry
Susan B Anthony your face doesn't want
to make people eat
but putting a transgender activist on a
chocolate bar that's gotta score a few
woke points even if the candy bar should
have been this one
but
it's one of my classic favorite
candy bars uh why am I bringing this up
that's a good question well it's another
example of a huge corporation signaling
to all that they're awoke which is the
same as saying hey please ignore our
sweatshops slave labor and unhealthy
products if we call you the right
pronouns you might not mind the diabetes
we gave your parents and the fat asses
we gave your kids
but this is the nature of corporate
America however it could be changing a
study from business.com do we have to
stillsay.com
it claims that job Seekers with
non-binary gender pronouns on their
resumes are less likely to be contacted
which is interesting but why are we
telling them this they already and
moan about enough stuff and if they keep
the pronouns on their resume it's a
perfect red flag for companies to steer
clear of these idiots
but maybe it's a good sign maybe
companies have learned that the
hysterical obsession with identity can
harm your company pretty bad I mean look
at Disney It's So Bad Peter Pan started
identifying as Tinkerbell
now she's out of work running drugs for
the Pirates of the Caribbean
turning tricks for Goofy
you didn't know he was a pimp did you
so apparently they sent out two fake
resumes one that included pronouns they
them under the person's name and one
that didn't they used a gender ambiguous
name Taylor Williams which was also my
stage name when I used to dance at the
bent carrot
back when that was cool now they got
drugs for it
turns out those with the pronouns got
eight percent less interest than the one
without and fewer interview requests too
the lesson it's always best to go the
Brian killmead route wait to disappoint
people after you're hired
so it appears some companies saw they
slashed them and thought this person
might be an a slash hole
they do the same thing with resumes that
say Keith olberman
and follow-up interviews with hiring
managers confirmed it here's some of the
quotes take off the pronouns I would
trash the resume for that reason alone
I'm not interested in the drama that a
person who thinks they are they them
brings with them it's a great point
personal pronouns are better reserved
for social settings not in a job setting
so it makes sense a resume should just
be the list of the jobs you've been
fired from
and lies about your charity work for
years I claimed I rescued Baby Jessica
from a well
okay
when in fact I was the one who put her
there
not to hire the woke a new study from
Baylor University explains how woke
employees terrorized their bosses into
following their silly religion it turns
out that power hungry middle management
places in places like HR or marketing
they guarantee themselves a job by
creating woke initiatives that no one
can comprehend and therefore criticize
it's brilliant how dare you fire me I'm
the company's only non-binary person of
color who helped launch be kind to gay
orphans day
fire me and that's homophobia
and since wokism has its own made-up
language those who can wield it can
appear more capable than those who don't
as the Wall Street Journal explains the
diversity equity and inclusion jargon
alone makes such initiatives difficult
for Outsiders including top managers to
understand and thus to challenge the
result these middle managers play a huge
role in spreading this left-wing
ideology to corporate culture
researchers even concluded there's
actually little evidence of systematic
support for their
but exec screen light them anyway out of
fear that their younger subordinates or
outside Consultants will rat them out
meaning it's a grift you know what I
know it everyone knows it yet it still
goes on because of cowardice
so the next time a resume with a Litany
of pronouns lands on your desk hire them
if they're the best qualified that's
what companies should have been doing
all along but let's keep the activism
where it belongs and Larry kudlow's hot
tub
[Applause]
Mr Roblox
this guest is so perky she doesn't own a
coffee pot Republican strategist Aaron
perini
he's so rich Scrooge McDuck sends him
hate mail host of making money on Fox
Business Charles Payne
and finally she's like that South Pole
always cold and often seen covered with
penguins
Fox News contributor captain
foreign
because you're the business dude
um what about this this idea of like
creating kind of a fiefdom within a
company using this rhetoric I've seen
this happen and you can't let those
people go because they only know the
secret words and then if you get in
trouble they're the ones that are going
to get you out of it so in a weird it's
like these Road Consultants create the
problem so that they can offer the
solution does that make sense it makes
sense and it's it's blown up from a
cottage industry into a real force uh in
in the corporate America and you know
watching companies try to deal with this
is absolutely amazing but you know I was
looking at the actual poll itself and
yeah 59 said that you know having this
non-binary thing would hurt your chance
of someone who's getting a job the other
part the one percent said it would be
very helpful so I'm like what gigs are
they going for
I hate to say it but yes what job is
like I hope I get one of these resumes
today I do have advice though
for Millennials living at home with Mom
and Dad who don't want to go to work but
they're getting a lot of pressure from
your parents send out your resume and
put day them Tyrone Jones
and you can honestly tell Mom and Dad
I'm trying I'm sending out directing me
all day long
he said it's true though you know uh uh
Professor long it's good to see you it's
always good to be back yeah yeah I know
it was kind of a court ordered
um sabbatical well I wouldn't you know
we agreed yeah yeah yeah
um and you know those those theater
Majors they tend to accuse people of a
lot of things let me tell you something
about theater Majors they lie and they
are convincing
so the thing is they them pronouns could
work for some jobs for example at Disney
but if you're going to be hired for in
construction you know this is not going
to work so why would you do this and
nine percent may not sound like a lot
but every little bit helps when you're
looking for a job oh yeah I mean I think
I think that person said it best like
why are you looking for trouble like
you're looking for the person who's not
going to give you trouble but I mean
honestly the problem with all the
pronouns is that they each each person
has their own set like you're not even
sure that they're consolidating unifying
under one alternate set of pronouns like
well I'm they them but I'm also yeah
right we're not using pronouns anymore
you're gonna use your first name it's
going to be no pronouns are ever allowed
I I suspect the problem here is that
like HR that we know the phrase HR yes
like 20 years ago was was Personnel no
me Personnel like nobody said it was one
little old lady yeah with glasses right
had the little thing that went around
her head yeah right and she knew what
vacation days and they were always less
than what you thought you had well you'd
go like oh I'm taking she goes now it
says here Greg that you only have two
days left that was when you could only
have like four days I uh I never had
that problem I was always a management
so I don't really have that issue but um
but yeah so until now like I have a
friend who was the who ran one of the
largest companies in the world right and
Jeffrey Epstein yes and I said to him uh
how much of your day was spent doing
Human Resources like a big company lots
of stuff going on he's at least 70
percent 70 of his job as the president
of company was HR stuff he said he'd
walk in the office in the morning and if
the president or the vice president
Executive Vice President of HR was
waiting for him he knew it was going to
be a really bad week yeah and that is
like you know that's going to take a
toll that's a doubt Aaron that would
keep me from from starting any business
this kind of stuff because if you look
at it from afar it is as though this is
a completely created artificial thing
that we never had a discussion about
whether we were going to accept all of a
sudden Jordan Peterson pointed this out
five years ago maybe about the heed the
pronoun things they're going to
compulsory compulsory speech being
forced to use this stuff and if you
don't use it you're in trouble so that's
an artificial creation then placed upon
us in the workplace and nobody has the
guts to say no thanks I don't get it
what do you see in this it's a fear of
cancel culture right you don't want to
be the business that has to deal with
the crisis comms moment that comes
because you insulted someone over their
chosen pronouns at the end of the day
work matters if you're hired to do a job
you should be able to do it it's about
being the most talented individual the
one that's a right fit and you shouldn't
be bringing your personal life and your
politics into your job right separate
church and state separate yourself from
your job I try to bring as little of my
personal self into my work so when I go
home I can maintain the balance between
work and life the more you bring of
yourself personally into the job the
more you're going to get yourself in
trouble create a line there there's no
reason you should cross the two oh that
is very hard for me
because I like I mean if I didn't bring
my personal life to work I'd have
nothing to talk about
I mean I don't even I don't I don't even
read the stories on the five you know
I'll just talk about something that
happened I think everybody will be
happier if you left your personal self
at home
I'm just speaking for some of the
employees here who often think
themselves if only Greg could just not
come in as Greg and just come in as
maybe somebody who cares about other
people I'm going to identify as you're
fired nope
cat what about
conversely what if it like what I think
you should be able to use these pronouns
if it helps you right like like let's
say you you really want this job and
you're not really that way you're not
really that way you should be able to
lie if you know it helps just like you
do with on any resume when you lie about
all sorts of crap
I've been thinking about it yeah for me
what would you be your uh oh like I'm a
she her a thousand percent like I'm a
girl excuse me I'm a woman
um and I just what if I did start going
by they them it could be worth it just
to see how you handle it yeah
every day I but I have to convince
everybody that I was totally serious
just to watch you squirm and be
uncomfortable and nervous and terrified
that to me sounds fun yes to make people
feel awkward yeah but I I guess there
should honestly if somebody's like okay
I'm evade them and then you I'll try to
call you that and you'd have to
understand sometimes people might mess
it up and be understanding I think
there's a huge difference between that
and the people who love it as an
opportunity for power and control it's
one thing to want acceptance and I'm all
for that it's another thing to be like
okay I can't wait until you up until I
can say that you did to show that I'm
better than you you know what that is
what you what you've identified is the
reason why the woke is so dangerous what
is power it's being able to tell
somebody they're wrong without the
Forgiveness yeah it's like that it's
like if you screw up in the woke
environment there is no forgiveness yeah
and if you try to argue back that's just
more evidence that you're right in
thinking that that person's
disrespectful it's bad for communication
it's bad for people connecting with each
other and it's actually if you claim to
want acceptance between people and
people to get along that's the last
attitude that you should think is good
also it kind of feels like and I know
this is I'm gonna trouble for this it's
a little bit like people who say they're
vegan it's like are you really vegan are
you just trying to be a pain in the ass
right yeah you know like secretly they
go and you know they're just eating the
cheeseburger and like ah I made
everybody uncomfortable and I kind of
sometimes get that vibe from the they
them I say I'm a vegan when I order a
burger and then I just claim that I'm
eating around the meat well
you're famous for that
apparently you did you did see my movies
from the 90s yeah you know uh you know
what I identify as as you know she it
can't can't believe that she it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else